[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook has censor live in
Qatar
England thump Wales in the Battle of
Britain will get the reaction to the
result and America beat Iran
thus Superstar Danish Striker and ITV
football pundit Nadia Nadeem on her
extraordinary Journey fleeing
Afghanistan as a child Refugee and
reaching the very top of international
football and commentating here at the
World Cup only for tragedy to strike
[Music]
live from Qatar this is Piers Morgan
uncensored at the World Cup
good evening from catarmonite where
England beat Wales three nil to book
their place in the World Cup last 16.
two second half goals and Marcus
rashford one from Phil Bowden secured
the win
cracking wind for England and also any
second now a cracking win it looks like
for the us against Iran which means they
will progress also to the last 16. so a
big night for England a big night for
America outside the Ahmad bin Ali
stadium is talking to these Holly Hudson
who's been there with England have been
frankly thrashing Wales Holly a great
night for England a brilliant result
nine goals now in this world cup for
England and not a single one for Harry
Kane
foreign
[Music]
I think Holly's waiting for me to talk
but unfortunately can't hear a word I'm
saying so we'll come back to Hollywood
we can try and restore the connection
I'm going to move on now to a aquatic
extraordinary story and this was brought
to my attention a week ago last Tuesday
where Nadia Nadeem who played for
Denmark over a hundred times one of the
top female players in the world was
commentating for ITV in a game involving
Denmark here at the World Cup when
incredibly sadly she discovered the news
that her mother had died back in Denmark
in a terrible Road accident where she
was hit by another vehicle
and it made me check in to her story and
it really is a quite remarkable story of
a young woman whose father was executed
by the Taliban who then fled with her
mother and sisters as refugees to
Denmark
when they got to Denmark she then built
a career as a football that became one
of the best female players to ever play
the game and as I'm speaking you can
hear that's the result in the U.S Iran
match it's official America has gone
through to the last 16 congratulations
to them and of course I'll talk to Nadia
about that let's take a look first of
all at a little package about anadia's
Journey so far to get here to This World
Cup
Nadia Nadine was born in Afghanistan at
the age of 11 her father a general in
the Afghan National Army was executed by
the Taliban
her mother fed the country with her five
daughters selling their possessions to
fund their escape
on forged passports they traveled by
Trump to Italy and went on to a refugee
camp in Denmark and it was there that
she discovered football after seeing a
group of children playing it over a
fence and despite not speaking any
English or Danish suggested to the coach
that she wanted to play and he let her
join in well Nadia went on to play for
the Danish national team over a hundred
times for her adopted Homeland
and last week Nadia was on air covering
the World Cup but her Joy at this career
high is a broadcaster was sadly
tarnished by the terrible news that her
mother had been killed in a road
accident let's have a look how the table
is after all that I'm afraid Nadia's had
to leave us at short notice despite
losing the person she called the most
important in her life Nadia returned to
work and was back on air within days
[Music]
and Nadia joins me now Nadia thank you
so much for joining me first my deepest
condolences to you on the loss of your
mother it was an awful thing to hear
about here at the World Cup we're all
aware of what had happened and you had
to leave very suddenly and then we found
out why your mother been killing them as
accident but it also made me go away and
research you and your life because I
didn't know much about you if I'm honest
and what I found was quite extraordinary
and I wanted to get you on the show just
to really talk about
so that's what's happened to you in the
last seven days but also to talk about
why your mother was so important to you
and this extraordinary Journey you went
on with her from Afghanistan to get you
to where you are today so thank you
first of all and my deepest condolences
as I say to you and all your family
you were commentating last week it was a
last Tuesday yeah and you suddenly get
told that your mother has died in this
awful accident yeah that for you must
have been just a given all you'd been
through together yeah a terrible moment
yeah definitely you know I think as you
said Tunisia versus Denmark sitting
there and I started receiving a lot of
messages from family no one was really
telling me what was happening everyone
was like have you heard are you on your
way and finally in second half I got to
I got a call from my cousin and he had
told me that my mom had passed away and
for the first 10 minutes I wasn't
believing it I was like I can't be my
mom was a healthy Woman and you know 57
years old
um
like I I couldn't really believe in
especially the way they told me it was
like an accident
um and yeah flew back home and yeah it
was the reality so definitely
heartbroken unexpected not only for me
but entire family and the the really sad
part of this was that she'd gone to the
gym early so that she could get back in
time to watch you commentating because
that was what she was so proud of and
you know that's just a Twist of faith
yeah yeah definitely I think yeah
one thing that I you I know for you know
in life for sure is that nothing's 100
and
everything can happen right away and
then as I said we did not expect it and
her dying that way is is hard uh
because I was you know expecting to live
and be with her for the next 20 years
um one of the closest persons in my life
I mean the closest person one of the
strongest women I've ever encountered in
my life and not just because she was my
mom but because the hardships she's been
going through
um and how she raised us you know five
kids alone actually took us from one
continent to another
and yeah losing her life that way I
heard me but on the other hand it's you
know I have her in me and her you know
Spirit her fighting mentality and now
I'm gonna do everything my hands to make
her friends no the mere fact you come
back to the world cup says that I mean
that's exactly the kind of spirit that
your mother had that she would have
wanted you to show and I want to take
you back now to Afghanistan
first of all you're living there with
your parents and your Four Sisters I
think you have yeah and your father is
in the Afghan military he's a general I
think is that right and he was murdered
by the Taliban when you were just 11
years old yeah what are your memories of
that awful time
uh I mean yeah 11 years old the Vivid
memories I remember everything it was a
very until that point you know I think
my life's been always very protective my
dad was General my mom was a school
teacher a lecturer later on and we've
always been very protected but after
Taliban gained power
killed my dad because obviously he had
to have a very high position in the in
the Army and everything off of that it
was just like chaos
we were trying to survive for a very
long time trying to make it in the
country but it was hard you know five
girls and a mom we went into hiding I
think yes quite a while yeah and then
you went to Pakistan you've got some
stolen passports and you eventually find
yourselves in Denmark I think you
thought you were going to England at one
stage yeah and a funny story huh
we have family in England and at that
point they obviously we want to be
reunited with their family but fate
didn't want us to end up in England for
some reason and honestly I don't really
care because we were together and we
were in safety and that's the point of
the entire thing and there's an amazing
moment you're in Denmark and you're in a
uh like an asylum Camp a refugee camp
and you look over a fence and you see
some kids playing football
and you've never played the game I don't
think until that point you don't speak
either English or Danish
but you're desperate to get involved and
eventually the coaches teaching these
kids says come on then you can join in
yeah what was it about football that you
were drawn to
I mean there's so many things I'm drawn
you know to to the game I remember one
of the first time I saw a girls team
play
the goals who are playing they looked
happy and they look free and me coming
from a country where I had to be in
hiding and always felt unsafe that was
something that attracted me and you'd
also been prevented from going to school
yes like by the Taliban yeah correct so
um I don't know it's just the game was
speaking to me and I wanted to be that
person on the field and you know it's
one of those moments struck by lightning
and my eyes were wide enough and I was
like I wanna I wanna be that kid and um
you know I have this I don't know I
always thought it was from my dad's side
this this fire inside of me but I for
sure know now it's from my mom's life I
do both right yeah I guess so it's a
combination
um yeah and it turns out you are
unbelievably good at football
in fact you go on to play for Denmark
over a hundred times you score in a
European Championship final you're a
brilliant player you're one of the great
female footballers there's ever been
and yet it was all really just
fortuitous the lack of the drawer of
life that took you from Afghanistan to
Denmark and then this remarkable career
fate yeah I do believe in fate uh and I
think also one of that's one of the
reason I can sit here today after less
than seven or Six Days Seven Days my mom
passed away because I'm I'm an emotional
person but I'm very also irrational
thinking you know I think what's meant
to be it's meant to be and I try to find
a positive situation I am in and I think
football gave me a life and you know my
background brought me to football and
then football gave me the life I have
today and and yeah when I want to take
it and I want to do as much as good
possible most people would say that's
enough
drama
horror
challenges for one life but not you
you've decided to become a doctor
and you're now involved in in surgery in
repairing bodies effectively right yeah
actually graduate as a doctor this
January January 14th I haven't finished
you know becoming surgeon yet this is
something I'm going to qualify whenever
I'm done but yeah a doctor is a big
thing my mom my mom that was one of her
wishes you know one of our kids to be a
doctor and and now she has two doctors
and two nurses and her family and then
yeah and you've been around
reconstructive surgeons I know yeah and
you talked about how some of the skills
you need to be are very super confident
football player actually a quite they're
quite similar to the skills you need to
be a top surgeon yeah definitely I think
you have to be able to
work on the pressure the responsibility
I really like and also feels like the
adrenaline that you have on the
surgeries uh it's very similar to
scoring it's scarier being in a surgical
room
with a real patient and trying to save
their life or playing a European
championship final
uh I don't think none of them mascara to
be honest they're both equally exciting
how many languages do you speak
quite a lot how many
fully around nine which ones
so I speak
Danish English French
German Hindi Persian that you would do
speak I understand no situation
Norwegian because they're quite similar
too is there anything you can't do that
probably is quite a lot of things I
don't know yet but if I start focusing
on them I'm probably gonna learn them I
mean it's a remarkable story
and I'm again so sorry about the loss of
your mother because it's now so apparent
to me why she was such a pivotal person
in your life you know you made this
journey with her from Afghanistan to
Denmark without her I guess none of you
would have made it
you're 100 correct and I you know I
really feel she gave us
life twice once when she gave birth to
me on second time when she took me from
Afghanistan to Denmark to have a better
future brighter future
and yeah it's someone that I'm gonna
always remember and I I want to remember
the gifts you know the happy memories I
had with her what kind of woman was your
name is hedima what kind of woman was
she
my mom was a very stubborn woman if she
once set her mind to something she'll go
for it and it didn't matter if the
entire world was against her she's very
intelligent
um and then
just like this little lady with so much
energy in her so much power and someone
who who people listen to and she touched
so many people's lives and even to a
funeral it was a Friday 9 30 and I we
just announced the day before because
I'm a Muslim and our religion you have
to bury you know as soon as possible
and there was like thousand people there
and then it just showed what kind of
human being she was someone who touched
people's hearts
do you feel like she's with you in
spirit yeah definitely I think that was
the reason I'm so calm I said I believe
in faith I believe she's in a bad place
and what's meant to be is meant to be
and for me to lay down and then you know
cry my eyes out for months and months I
don't think that's gonna fix anything
she's not gonna come back if that was
the case trust me I'll be the one doing
that so I try to you know take that
energy those emotions and put something
that that you know will remember her
honor her and hopefully for me you know
bring me food in life
you're only 34 years old
and you've experienced so much in your
life
what's what's next for you do you think
I hope that's drama in that way it's
less tragedy I hope that you know I can
I can grow into a person who can have an
impact not only on my life on people
around me but you know people who are in
need that's something that I'm
passionate about that's something my mom
was passionate about
um so yeah and I work hard for it
we're gonna talk football uh tonight
obviously
um what do you make of the World Cup so
far who are your picks to perhaps Win It
I honestly you've been enjoying the
World Cup here you know watching the
games at the stadium has been great
atmosphere for me there's a couple of
teams who've been doing very well I
think we can all uh agree on that Brazil
looks very sharp the reason for me
they're looking so good and probably one
of my favorites to win this tournaments
because they are so balanced as a team
they have great Strikers not one player
they have like you know four or five
that can decide games great Midfield
experience back and then two of the best
Premier League Keepers there is right
and France before the World Cup I was
counting them a bit out because they're
missing you know the engine and and uh
Pogba and kante but actually with the
two young midfielders they've been doing
very well you know what when you've got
killing and Batman up front and he's
playing like he is I guess you can win
anything
yeah that's that's fact well let's see
when the games are getting you know a
bit harder if he's gonna maintain a lot
of very excited American fans I mean
it's a massive moment for team us
because they've beaten Iran obviously a
very highly charged fixture that uh
historically a lot of tension building
up to it but America I've gone through
to the last 16. who knows maybe England
America in the final
that's very optimistic I'm sorry to say
so but you know what this world cup
shown that everything can happen if I
say to you will Saudi ever beat
Argentina you just said don't be
ridiculous that's true facts this is the
World Cup where Miracles are happening
stay with me that it feels like a short
break uh when we come back I'm gonna get
reaction to that England Victory could
England go all the way how far can U.S
go are we talking to experts on all
sides of the pond
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the biggest tournament in the world
and it just got bigger
Piers Morgan is in Qatar for the World
Cup as the competition heats up joined
by the biggest names in sports
the only place to be after the final
whistle
Piers Morgan uncensored live in Qatar on
Monday and Tuesday at the later time of
9pm on talk TV
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
makes sense opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan and
censored if you're wondering where we're
filming the show from we're here at this
remarkable Fox Sport Complex here in
Doha it's the Cornish heart of Doha in
Qatar and behind me they're actually
recording some shows for Fox Soccer Fox
Sports over in the states I've been
doing some punditry for them as well but
it really is remarkable the three
massive Studios and a host of stars
coming and going through the day and
Through the Night a a huge operation
with a lot of brilliant stuff we've also
been very kindly putting our show
together as well we thank you team for
everything you've been doing thank you
very much
[Applause]
we're talking your teams everyone I
think by now probably knows that my team
Allegiance is Arsenal Football Club so
I'm absolutely delighted to be joined by
the man who transformed my club from the
the mediocre minnows of the Premier
League so the all-conquering Champions
because he brought this strange guy in
called arsene benga who we'd never heard
of and he'd been in Japan who are like
he's lost his mind this guy but David
Dean knew what he was talking about he
was a vice Joan of Arsenal and the rest
is history won the league three times in
eight years a host of other trophies and
became the best team in the world
probably ever and David Dean is with me
now David great to see you and Nadia's
kindly agreed to stay with us David a
lot of speculation well first of all
your reaction to the result tonight
England what do you think very satisfied
it was we started off very slowly as a
bit of a pedestrian first half but
certainly woke up in the second half and
it was a very good accomplished
performance and I'm delighted for the
team and for all the fans who would have
thought that we could score nine goals
at a World Cup and Harry Kane wouldn't
get any of them there you go well
there's a good problem for Southgate to
have everyone's banging in goals apart
from the guy who normally does that's
right but you're you're only as good as
your last game you've got to keep
winning
what does Southgate doing now with this
team because he now there's a lot of
competition for places you brought Phil
foden back in yes I think Godfrey read
my column in the sun I'm not sure uh
demanding fodenster but he was great
tonight uh Marcus rashford was on fire
tonight I don't see how he can drop
rashford but he can't play rashford
Sterling Sakia Odom and Kane and mount
and grillish yes appears were all
frustrated managers aren't we and I can
see if we set Senegal in the next round
we've got right on Sunday evening I
think who would you put in that front
five I'm very pleased I'm not the
manager because he's got a he's got to
stand up to be counted he'll be judged
on his before on the team's performance
Daddy what do you think who would you
put now if you were Gary Southgate
obviously Kane start so who do you put
around Kane
who do you ruin their World Cup
I don't know I think Russia has been
choosing and then also like her because
I'm also Arsenal fans I think you've got
to play soccer on the right voting him
behind Kane rashford I mean one of
them's going on the left
and they can't vote could they it's a
pleasant problem to have yeah luxus
it's a good problem let's turn to the
World Cup more generally because David
you've been one of the top football
Executives for many decades now you know
how it all works let's start first of
all with all the noise around FIFA as an
organization you've dealt with them over
the years how much of the criticism is
Justified
well I think perhaps initially certainly
when the bid process went on it was
definitely flawed there's no question
about that however that was 12 years ago
we have to move on we've decided to put
a team into the World Cup we've
qualified and we've got to give it the
best support we possibly can and I
really feel sorry for people who haven't
come out here because they're missing a
lot they're missing a phenomenal
tournament I have personally seen 15 out
of the last 16 World Cups my first World
Cup was 19. how many have you seen 15
out of the last six out of six
no no I'm talking about World Cups all
right behind the games how many games
four a day I mean I've been in heaven
I've been obviously going around with us
we've been seeing four games a day out
of all the games we've only missed two
out of uh I just want to interrupt
because the man chanting Piers Morgan is
a legend and I wouldn't like to think
the cameras hadn't picked that up so
that's what I make sure we got that on
camera you sure he didn't say leg end
how many World Cups have you been to
World Cups have been I the first one was
1966 of Wembley when we won it I was one
yes I've been to 15 since they're
missing out one in 1982 in Spain
otherwise 15 World Cups and appears out
of all of them this has to rank right at
the top this is as good if not better
than any other it is not enough I saw
Graham Sooners this morning he said the
same thing it's been phenomenal the
whole organization of it you know people
are quick to criticize and slow to
praise Qatar deserve a lot of praise for
the way they've put it on last night we
went to the game at Lucille Stadium it
finished at five to twelve I was back in
the hotel at quarter past 12. couldn't
do that I think politics ever get
involved with sport
I don't I don't think so because where
does it ends Ford is a sport football is
a sport and we've got to treat her as
such and once you start introducing
politics we're in trouble because we
could have 32 countries here with
different political messages where does
it end all of which have their own
problems and you know FIFA do deserve
some credit and I think Johnny Infantino
particularly the president obviously
everybody gets it's easy to criticize
somebody but it's been a magnificent
World Cup you can't ever I mean the
accommodation has been great the
transport has been look I think
the problem he felt to me was that press
conference he gave where he slightly
overegged the souffle he went on a bit
too passionately and when he began
telling everybody I'm gay I'm Arabic and
I'm everything else I was like where is
this going to finish he's like he seemed
to be everything but don't forget he has
been a bit he's been a bit hammered by
certain members of the press sure uh I
don't think you're amongst that but are
you yes what did you make of it another
I mean it's a hard job running a FIFA
um but I knew what he was trying to say
he was trying to say look there's a lot
of hypocrisy which I think there is I've
been on this myself but the he probably
slightly over did it yeah definitely I
think you know
I don't think he knows how it feels to
truly be uh and someone else's shoes
that way he always explaining that but I
think his message was kind of that
that we should be a bit more tolerant
you know and then and football is the
beautiful game that can unite and that's
and it it's for everyone uh and this
region deserves also to experience World
Cup and I think it's gonna do great
things for the region not only for Qatar
um you've had a bit of criticism back
home yeah everybody who seems to come in
I got criticized for coming I don't care
whether you think I should not I've been
in the Middle East a lot in my life I
like the Middle East a lot of people
here I think they deserve a bit more
respect for what they're doing here and
that doesn't mean you ignore the areas
where they could certainly be improving
but I don't think England's in any great
shape to install their moral virtue on
other countries what do you think of
this argument about the morality of it
all uh honestly as you said I I've to be
honest I don't really understand that
for me
this was the decision that was been
taken 12 years ago and now that we're
here we should try to make the best out
of it I think every there's problems
everywhere and and trying to highlight
one thing
extremely for so long time I think a bit
too much uh what I see in the way is
that football is a great tool to bring
change to educate to improve just
the fact that we're sitting here talking
about about you know what could be
better that's a oh my God that's a
change you could spin any of these
numbers like I mean there are so many
millions of migrants at two and a half
million migrants here how many countries
would allow 90 odd percent of their
population to be migrants right and they
come here to earn more money than they
could from the countries they come from
in almost every case yes there have been
a number of deaths yes those should be
investigated yes the conditions have had
to be improved so therefore that's an
emission thing's not as good as they
should be but I was speaking to some
women yesterday Qatari women everyone in
Qatar gets free education for example I
didn't know that they said there's
gender pay equality throughout all
official bodies including the government
um and so on and so on it's not quite
how people may be in Denmark or England
think it is here
no I don't think that's correct exactly
you know I think some of the western
media has been taking one thing and kind
of spinning it and a lot of people that
come here they say well I was imagining
something totally differently and then
to be a very Frank you know it's not
because I'm trying to build your like
you know paint your picture does not but
I'm just whether it deserves credit you
should give it and for me this woke up
so far has been brilliant
David
putting on a World Cup it's an
unbelievably difficult thing and I think
we can all agree that so far it's run
very very well no traffic problems the
stadiums are out of this world if you
want a drink you can get one very easily
in restaurants and bars all over the
town hotels there's no real problem with
that I personally rather like the fact
the fans can't all get drunk inside the
stadiums because I was at the Wembley
Euros final last year and frankly it was
a complete disgrace yeah I agree with
you and the capacity they're running now
at 97 capacities of actually every
stadium is full every day that
atmosphere tonight America Iran yeah was
probably the best atmosphere so far
there you go well I thought Argentina
Mexico was really rich I mean that was
wonderful they're nearly 90 000 people
and a lot of the Argentinian fans the
Mexican fans were side by side you know
and I mean that for FIFA this has been a
phenomenal success it really has what
about what about the allegations which
are swirled around FIFA for decades of
corruption you you know all these people
yeah we know that a lot of them have
been taught with their fingers in the
till so the corruption has clearly been
real and clearly been going on should
FIFA go through a wholesale Reformation
do you think well no but I think In
fairness when Johnny and fan don't
forget he inherited that mess and to his
great credit I think he's actually
cleaned up the show so I think he
deserves something for that for the way
FIFA currently being run of course
everybody's going to be critical he's
got 211 mouths to feed everybody not
everybody's going to be satisfied that
goes with the territory I mean there's
huge eruptions we can be cynical but
meanwhile this tournament will gross
something like seven billion dollars
right you've got to say that is a huge
success
it's wonderful it's when it all gets
recycled back into football around the
world I certainly think that if you're
walking around Qatar I know you've had
to sadly to leave to beat your mother's
funeral but I've been here for five days
now I'm just walking around and Milling
around the regular fans of all around
the world a you get a sense of the scale
of a World Cup the sheer volume of
countries supporters walking around with
flags and everything secondly a lot of
Happiness no real incidents no fighting
no vomiting industry I mean it's been a
very feels like a very safe and happy
event to me yeah definitely I've been
enjoying it um as you said you know the
atmosphere of the vibe is very very nice
pleasant
um safe the fans are enjoying themselves
The Fan zones are full uh I've been a
couple of times and you know Fan
Festival
um yeah what's it mean like to be a
woman in Canada for you
oh wait for me it's been the same as it
is everywhere you know I felt safe and
like it's like in U.S and Europe um as I
said it's it's it's very hard to point
fingers if you haven't really experience
in yourself and this is a way for us to
educate you know I think football has
that power to educate tea because you
you read something or you heard
something without actually being also
for you coming from Afghanistan where
you were deprived in education by the
Taliban and now millions of young girls
in Afghanistan are once again being
deprived in education by the Taliban to
come to a country like Qatar which is a
small country but where education is
free for all including all girls
I mean that's not a thing to turn our
noses up at no I think that's amazing I
think that's a great example to set that
should that should be a norm anywhere
you know free education
but it's unfortunately that's David case
who is going to win the World Cup come
on you know your football uh well I
think that he wasn't far wrong when she
I think you went for Brazil Brazil I
think France won't be too far away I
don't think Portugal will be far away
they won't be they look good and I have
to tell you yesterday was one I mean we
are seeing I mean I'm obviously I'm
going around a lot with our sin we saw
we're seeing four games a day and
yesterday after the Ghana game uh where
they were playing Korean it was a
wonderful game of football yeah we were
coming to Lucille for the final fourth
game I said to Mom said are you ready
for another game he said I'm ready for
two
with this will be unique you will not
see another world cup with four games
can England win it put your neck
if we win all the next games we can win
it
I think we can beat Senegal then we're
in the quarterfinals right and who knows
anything can happen in the World Cup
you've been there you've been in the
European final yeah
anything can happen that's football you
know yeah
listen thank you particularly for coming
back uh to the World Cup that takes a
lot of guts and I send my very best to
you and all your family as well and I
can see the spirit of both your father
and your mother and you without ever
having met them but knowing what they
did I can see it in you so thank you
very much thank you and David great to
see you as always I bet you better get
your bag because you presume you're off
another four games tomorrow yeah well
only two I'm afraid we can't do before
but we'll be I'll be final aggression
for you Arsenal Five Points clear in the
Premier League is it coming back are we
going to win the League this season I
think we have a decent chance uh because
everybody can beat everybody this year
do we need to buy a top striker in I
think they have to be bold in the
transfer market in January it would be
nice
what about Cristiano Ronaldo
I'm not going to comment put in my front
with Jay-Z's then you'd have God and
Jesus that's a good combination
that's a good one we shouldn't have
thought of that I thank you both very
much great to see you thank you very
much indeed well next tonight more
reaction tonight's result from Team USA
I'll talk to Kobe Jones the most cap us
player in history there he is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
it's the biggest tournament in the world
and it just got bigger
Piers Morgan is in Qatar for the World
Cup as the competition heats up joined
by the biggest names in sports
the only place to be after the final
whistle
[Applause]
Piers Morgan uncensored live in Qatar on
Monday and Tuesday at the later time of
9pm on talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
sense opinions that matter so don't miss
first edition with me Tom Newton Dunn
each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan on censored
which is live from Doha and Qatar seen
of course of the World Cup I'm joined
now by the most capped U.S International
football player refused to use the word
soccer on this set Toby Jones Toby
welcome to you thank you for joining me
from the the fox
they call it Fox Soccer it's Fox
football we know that right no no I I
appreciate you having me here but I do
want you to understand
since we did play better in the England
game is it soccer now
that's one of the most irritating things
you know the worst statistic in World
football football is that England have
never beaten America in the competitive
game of football amazing isn't it it's
never happened I know I I trust me I
know
the other thing I'm hoping for is that
we get to the final against you and just
destroy you well well it's good to want
it's good to hope you know when you have
those realities right now I think
everybody around the world thinks that
the US is a better team based off of
that performance where the US played
very well only you lock and celebrate a
nil nil draw yeah I'm celebrating as if
you somehow reinvented the the Civil War
or something it's like it's not
happening
um let me ask you about
America as a as a well as tall as soccer
because in America you call it soccer
how big is the sport now I mean it's
always been a sport it seems to me that
that people boys would play until they
were 16 17 and then gravitate to other
sport bigger for young girls and young
women
but now it seems to me it's on the cusp
potentially of breaking through the
ratings for Fox have been huge This
World Cup record numbers the team looks
as good as it's ever been what do you
feel
I I feel that it's here it's here to
stay it's established itself as a major
sport and it's only continuing to grow I
think moments like this when you talk
about the World Cup this is when you see
the exponential growth because it's been
a steady growth and and then every World
Cup it grows it has these Leaps and
Bounds and that was a big problem of
when we did not qualify in the last
World Cup but now I mean from everything
that I've seen and everything that I'm
hearing back in the States it's taking
off to another level once again you put
164 games
yeah it wasn't it wasn't a lot of time
it was all squeezed in and packed in and
and I'm and I understand like the the
fan that really doesn't know a lot about
that or what a cap is as far as
representing your country it might not
seem like a lot but that's quite a bit
you know because you know the norm it's
like celebrated if you get a hundred
caps you know and I and I feel that I
was honored to to represent I've always
had a bunk bed the American sport you
tend to call yourselves world champions
in sports only Americans are allowed to
play
you're now in a tournament which
actually genuinely does have the rest of
the world allowed to compete against you
would it be the Pinnacle of American
sport to actually win a World Cup that's
genuinely a world event
well look first off for all the other
sports everyone's invited feel free feel
free to participate if you like it I'm
going to bring the British baseball team
there we go yeah go for it but look if
we win the World Cup I think that would
would uh set a mark like no other
because we are looked upon within within
the soccer World as ah they're just
starting out they don't know so if we do
get to a point where we get even get to
a final that's gonna really have a a
profound impact I think on the game
itself
it seems to me looking at the team young
hungry Dynamic I think average age was
24 tonight and the game against a much
older more experience to run and they
came through it the one thing you're
lacking as a team is a top Striker would
that be fair I would say that's fair how
can you have 320 million people
and neither strike it we're still
looking we're still developing we've
only got 60 million we've got buckets of
them yeah but you've been playing the
sport for hundreds of years
I've learned you into my track you've
just been playing longer that's all you
know but we're getting there in a short
amount of time we're getting there and
it's not a a an issue only for the US
there's a lot of teams that that even at
this world cup that have a history that
are still trying to figure out who their
Striker is going to be foxes I think
rather cleverly uh Fox Sports have kept
out of all the politics it's been
swirling around the tournament which
seems to me to be massively overblown
you've played a lot of football at
International level what do you think
just generally about politics and Sport
I mean it seems to me in recent years a
lot of Sportsmen from Colin Kaepernick
to LeBron James and American we've had
the same in England with a lot of Marcus
rashford and others
um wanting to to get involved in social
justice issues racial Justice all that
kind of thing is it does that blur the
line between politics and sport or not
or should Sportsman do you think use
their brands and their success to wider
messages well I think within within the
the various events themselves me
personally I would like to see it stick
to sport but I do think the athletes
should use their platform that they have
to speak to the issues that are
important to them you know so it is a
little bit of a combination of both but
for me I I love
I I love sport with the passion because
of what it brings you know for people
and everything that you can learn about
it and it breaks down barriers and
allows people from different cultures
earlier about her extraordinary story
which I didn't know much about but to go
from Afghanistan as a refugee to Denmark
with your four sisters and your mum your
dad's been killed by the Taliban and you
end up in Denmark and you see kids
playing football across a fence and you
beg to play and then you become
Denmark's most capped female player and
an iconic figure in female football but
quite amazing it is but that's what
football can do right yeah that's what
football can do that's what sport can do
that's why it's so important that
everyone has the opportunity to play
because that sport really does bring
everyone together it's the common
language and the World Cup in particular
I think you've played in three World
Cups every World Cups yes a lot of
people saying this is the best World Cup
they've been to in terms of organization
what do you think I think it's a great
world cup I think one of the big things
that we see here it's a smaller area so
you have that opportunity especially for
the fan to go to various games a lot of
people who've walked around all day and
watch four games yeah they've walked 12
miles right that's amazing that you can
go see a game in the morning and see a
game and they mean I don't think we'll
we'll have another world cup where
you'll be able to do that the next one
is coming to America along with Canada
and Mexico what will you be calling it
when FIFA bring the football World Cup
to America uh the greatest soccer event
ever
damn you okay great to see you pleasure
thank you very much appreciate you
coming up well thanks for that more
reaction and workout predictions don't
go away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the biggest tournament in the world
and it just got bigger
Piers Morgan is in Qatar for the World
Cup as the competition heats up joined
by the biggest names in sports
the only place to be after the final
whistle
Piers Morgan uncensored live in Qatar on
Monday and Tuesday at the later time of
9pm on talk TV
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
makes sense opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
live here in Doha Qatar which of course
the venue this year for the World Cup
I'm joined Now by a friend of Piers
Morgan uncensored Aviation expert Alex
macherus who's lived between Doha and
London Alex great to see you good to see
you we know we told you about Aviation
right it's been a big story of course
the last few years but I've also been
aware that you often join us from Doha
correct uh from your Skype from your
your home here would you come and go to
yeah you've lived for a long time on and
off
I suppose the obvious question is are we
being sold a bit of a mythological view
of Qatar has it all been created to make
us feel this way about Qatar while the
World Cups I think I think what you have
experienced on this trip and what I know
you've been doing since you've been here
I think you have actually got to know
Qatar for what it is and I think that's
been the consensus among fans who have
traveled here experience what people are
calling one of the best World Cups ever
going to multiple matches today the
other day I was at three matches you
know the unique nature of this
tournament combined with the hospitality
that qataris are famous for that the
Middle East is famous for and the way
that this place has developed since they
got the videos
it's changed physically the skyline
behind us has changed its change in
terms of infrastructure is changing the
fact that now you can have over a
million people arriving to the airport
clear immigration in five minutes almost
a million riding the Metro every day
going between games but also Society has
been ready for for this world cup you
know is the place perfect where is as
you've been saying but I think this has
been an important project that they've
been focused on that they have been able
to make great reforms as a result and
it's been a chance for the whole world
to gather here it is
I also want to play a clip from last
night my interview with Hassan al-tawadi
he's really missed a World Cup right in
which he made a concession about the
number of Migrant workers who've died
just yeah play this
do you know how many migrant workers
have died as a result of any
construction since the announcement of
the bid we decided to capture and we
made a decision in terms of obviously
work-related deaths as defined under the
you know industry standard but also
capturing what we consider to be
non-work related deaths and this is only
purely in relation to the stadiums right
and the projects that we're responsible
for and what are those people and that's
three work-related deaths and 37
non-work related deaths what is the
honest realistic total do you think of
Migrant workers who've died from as a
result of what they're doing for the
World Cup in totality
the estimate is around 400. before
between 400 and 500 I don't know I don't
have the exact number
an interesting admission has made a lot
of news actually around the world that
admission because everyone has taken a
figure from The Guardian of six and a
half thousand which people quickly words
out was not accurate that was the total
number of Migrant workers you've died of
anything in the last 12 years and that's
natural causes included but to say that
four to five hundred migrant workers
have died over probably a 10-year period
here in all construction around the
entire city it's not a small amount of
people it's not and of course no one is
going to diminish the the the the
travesties of that but I think what's
important is that you know hassanville
ideas has come forward to to ultimately
speak up about it when you're asking him
the questions I think a lot of the time
they find in this place that they're
never given the chance to provide those
answers or they're running with as you
say Guardian articles
um and there are reforms in place I mean
I'm sure you know over there well
they're definitely made labor law
reforms and that is a significant part
of the Legacy for Mr World Cup along
with with other things now I want to
show you a scenes of Americans
celebrating earlier their win uh tonight
over Iran big game obviously
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my God
[Applause]
can you sit down please I mean imagine
what they're like if they actually win a
quarter final unbelievable oh it's
coming home dude
you can't actually come home if it's
never a been created here and you've
never won it before we are taking it oh
Big Night Big Night congratulations to
your teams you know what let's just
agree it's my last night for now until
we get to the final obviously in in
Qatar we've had a few little squabbles
along the way but tonight United in
celebration of two good victory this is
coming together of two great Nations two
great suckering Nations that have come
together in Victory and moving on to
bigger and better things and who knows
maybe in the future we will meet again
how you doing man good to meet you I
mean I'm seeing evidence
here really in a way you're outnumbered
a lot of people saying it's the best
World Cup they've been to what do you
feel I love it I mean it's there's this
there's this brigadoonish type of
experience that we have here this magic
that is here everybody's obviously in
the same place there's no traveling I
think it's been wonderful yeah I mean
discovering the land uh discovering the
people well the people have been
wonderful here we've had some great
soccer you know what I thought I was
going to ask you about this I've had
probably a dozen now local Qatari people
right they've come up to me actually
most wanted to talk about the Ronaldo
interview which they watch and have a
chat but then all offering me the chance
to go back and to their homes and have a
meal they all want to give me this is it
this is the unique nature of this World
Cup
we had people who had Qatari families
outside of stadiums putting on a whole
spread for free for fans who are going
to try local Qatari food whilst walking
into the games probably that second or
third game of the day I mean he said one
guy I said to him I'm very kind but
unfortunately I haven't got time I'm
going back and he said okay no problem
love it to me went off I went to pay my
bill in the restaurant like an hour
later he paid it but that's that is my
experience of local Qatari people very
thrilled to have people is Morgan
effects
they've been wonderful wonderful food
wonderful uh just hospitality and to
your point we are guests here we are
guests in this incredible country with
this incredible history and they want to
make sure that we have a good time and
obviously take the message back to
everybody
team us have to play better than you
just sang oh my God to make to make the
final score I would hope so I would hope
that they uh how far can they go do you
think well we got the Dutch next yeah
[Laughter]
going tomorrow morning but I may come
back if england get to the final if well
so what's when or when you should come
back and watch the US I I would say I
miss you I'm not sure I go that far but
I've liked our bonding this way it's
been one thank you very much for coming
thank you thank you Alex great to see
you we've had some fun too that's it
from me I'll be back usual time in
London tomorrow night live at 8 o'clock
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
that's me saying good night from Doha in
Qatar it's been a fantastic few days
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's the biggest tournament in the world
and it just got bigger
all right
Piers Morgan is in Qatar for the World
Cup as the competition heats up joined
by the biggest names in sports
the only place to be after the final
whistle
[Applause]
Piers Morgan uncensored live in Qatar on
Monday and Tuesday at the later time of
9pm on talk TV
[Music]
foreign